I think I'm done I need maybe like five
more hours
I have probably 20 different types of
piping tips I use anything from macarons
KitKat's
and I've gotten really good at making a
really nice drip on the side of most of
my cakes I do a little bit of baking for
fun sometimes but I'm mostly successful
in drawing it's I think I have a pretty
strong chance at being good at this
because I have an eye for design in
color
[Music]
promise is like celebrating high school
and how great it was yeah okay I
remember going to a midnight rendezvous
senior prom and I want to incorporate
that into my mini cake for my cakes I'm
gonna decorate them to look like coke
cans because teenagers like things that
look like other things definitely gonna
stack it up like on top of each other
I kind of like it to be a cylinder I
made the first cut I'm scared oh you
didn't measure huh no measure I'm
measuring I'm measuring just because
we're making we're making four of the
same thing
[Music]
the first prom that I could have gone to
I got grounded because I was on Facebook
too much nobody studying I wanna
probably stick to like a dirty coat like
a naked grip kind of look for this dirty
and naked pretty much looks pretty okay
got my tower of Cakes I'm gonna roll
some fondant
cuz font done doesn't taste great but it
looks good wait do I need to do a crumb
coat that's a fun feeling like this is
messier than I thought originally just
because I'm not used to working with
things so tiny overall I feel like I'm
on track I think it's going pretty okay
I like how the shapes turning out it's
not it's like even as I want it to be
but I think this is going in the right
direction I really I'm not great with
fondant so I feel like I'm just gonna
play off of my strengths and work with
like icing and buttercream I'm gonna try
to place this on top of my cake now even
ish things are falling apart a little
bit okay
nothing I can't handle it like I'm just
trying to figure it out as I go
[Music]
that's really good fondant work though
yeah better than I could do we're being
very British right now by being nice to
each other the engine what what why no
what okay okay oh yeah you know what I
can do this I made these little Crescent
fondant things and maybe I'm just gonna
have it so that it rests on the gummy on
top of the cake sweaty
harder
[Music]
we're done we did it we did it okay I
think I did pretty okay I mean I just
took what I knew and made it into a
smaller cake I feel like there are
miniature versions of cakes that I
usually would make I think I did a
pretty good job trying to make four
identical cakes I went a little
overboard with the buttercream in the
end but overall I'm pretty happy with it
it was a learning process I think I did
okay
I did better than I feared I think I set
myself for a lot bit off more than I can
chew and I think I did too
we'll see how the the judging goes this
one the coke I'm into a little bit more
cuz it's a little more like modern and
you could always sneak alcohol into prom
in a coke can
so yeah I'm feeling like this one is a
little more me I would say that the
cocaine is definitely more of a rigid
idea and they used the little gummies as
like a soda pop opener so I'm gonna have
to go originality here but I'd be more
excited about this cake I like the
lettering of this one a lot colors good
very iconic Beauty good tab detail these
ones look like little wedding cakes
which I guess is kind of prom me this is
like Instagram II and also I hate that I
just said that please don't put that in
the video this one is just like much
more thematically cool I don't know who
was drinking coke at prom maybe their
prom theme was like Twilight moon for
prom
I guess I'm picking this one I like it
when people make cakes that look like
something you should be both very good I
think I'm gonna give it to us these are
really not going to socks off I feel
like we should be holding hands like
we're at a pageant yeah no matter what
happens we'll still be friends
[Music]
writing rights yeah congratulations
I had a lot of fun this was just like
really fun learning experience good job
[Music]